you know I shouldn't remember how I met
the cigar so brothers all I know is that
they were too attractive looking Asian
men who I assumed for a gay couple is it
region house this is Ben yeah as much as
me David said don't go back there cuz he
has a surprise mrs. dorset Rose are our
brothers that are really close like if
you look at their Instagram and you
follow them on on Twitter or whatever
they have like this kind of like
incestual brother that freaked me out at
first I know but it turns out they're
just really loving brothers which is
borderline I'm pretty sure one of them
suck each other
so because Yoshi is here and if you guys
don't know who Yoshi Yoshi is the Power
Ranger on Power Rangers Dino force and
in order for me to do that show the
original power matrix now my do like
when you buy a blue Power Ranger out but
you can't just walk in any store and get
it on which is like Halloween I actually
had ordered that [ __ ] off Amazon but
they said they gave you the dimensions
for it but it turns out the dimensions
were off and I just look like a blue
[ __ ] condom that [ __ ] was so tight
the mask would even go over my head
s'up [ __ ] look in you it of course
you did you will love it but me I feel
like I'm like the older brother these
two little weirdos you know every
tradition we have Isis for ICU yeah I
have to do this
every time I see him I had to slap him
in his little ass no no what the great
thing is about spandex doesn't my big
it's okay gennadi hey it's okay
now family can you for the masks over so
I know
Yoshi usually gets a slap too but I kind
of gave him a pass this time in
congratulations for him becoming the
blue Power Ranger but Peter for sure how
to get one because he's always a little
smartass oh I'm gonna take this off now
somebody unzip me we were all my
governess look at that [ __ ] oh if you
guys have ever been inside a polyester
that's not supposed to be on your body
that's two sizes extra small
you will know what true heat feels like
there Oh God
it's kind of funny because it was a
pretty cold day but I gotta tell you
about three or four minutes inside that
suit I was sweating inside of it and you
don't like when sweat touches polyester
it kind of recreates the scratchy feel
to it it was one of the most
uncomfortable feelings on earth but in
order to pursue the comedic relief of
the moment that it needed I don't know
if that makes that sentence make sense
but [ __ ] it I had to do it back along
sighs yes I read the measurements and I
Hanna and I measured everything out and
when it came in they didn't go over my
head like you're supposed to have it
halfway zip and then do that and then
pull it up I think if I put my head
through it it would just burst it okay
alright hobros